in good shape your health magazine on DW
featuring an interview with a different
expert every week
with me in the studio with a full head
of hair is dr. andreas FINA he's a hair
and scalp specialist and he carries out
hair transplants dr. veena welcome to in
good shape and we just saw you in the
report but first to this autohemotherapy
what do you think about that it's a new
treatment option that involves injecting
your own platelets into the scalp we
don't have a lot of studies about it but
people may want to try it out if the
standard treatment is not enough or if
they think they want to try out
something people are trying out
everything believe me if it comes to
hair loss we've got a letter from
Thailand our viewer Peter Schmidt had
some visual disturbances so he was
trying some yoga exercise with the
shoulder stand it's like a headstand at
on the shoulders and he recognized that
his hair which previously fell out is
growing back in a nice brown color so do
you think this this kind of shoulder
stand could actually help patients with
hair loss it's an interesting report but
I don't think most hair loss conditions
are due to a problem with blood flow so
it's interesting but in most patients
what I see is that the blood supply is
very good even if they are bold so this
could work over the blood supply and
making new hair grow that's the idea but
I don't think it's worth trying out for
everybody it's better to see a
specialist and see what's going on and
when should you exactly see a specialist
so how many hair can fall out we say
it's normal and when should you see a
specialist one reason would be if you
would lose too much hair for a long
period of time which you usually didn't
and the other reason would be if you're
thinning and if you noticing smaller and
shorter hair
the first reason could be diffuse hair
loss right with many factors the second
reason could be genetics thinning okay
and if you go to the doctor and he said
I will prescribe you some pills the
standard treatment for that so how good
are pills like minoxidil and finasteride
for treating hair loss for genetic hair
loss we have these two treatment options
but it's mostly preventive like you
should start
and then also use it continuously for
many years and with the minoxidil lotion
or foam over to finasteride pill for men
we can mostly see that the hair loss is
stabilized and so they don't lose more
so if you don't want to take those drugs
you can go and get a hair transplant so
how is it actually done and who's
eligible for getting this treatment we
you have to look how many hair the
person has in the donor area which is
usually the back of the scalp because
those hairs are not sensitive to
testosterone to the male hormone and
that's why they will always survive even
in the front so what I look at is the
back of the Hat like the donor hair but
also how much is needed and if that
matches we can do it so but if you take
hair away from the back of the head it's
gone and so how you bought at the back
of the head then of course we don't take
everything either we take a small piece
and separate the hairs under the
microscope or we take one by one but not
everything so it's not visible in the
back and you can just take your own hair
you can just say my wife is great here I
wanted to be blonde anyway so I just
take the the hairs of my wife no you can
only use your own hair because it's like
a little organ which would be rejected
if it would be from another person dr.
veena what are some of the causes that
make hair fall out this way increased
shedding can be caused by operations
medications diets stress or hormonal
changes so that has to be evaluated in
the hair clinic in the hair clinic and
so if the doctor finds out one of the
causes and he treats the cause doesn't
mean that the hair can grow back yes in
most cases it will grow back after some
months unless there's also some genetic
problem with the regrowth okay what
about this so-called spotted baldness
where patches of hair fall out what's
the reason for that yeah this is called
alopecia areata and it's because hair
roots are having misunderstanding with
immune cells and fall asleep in some
spots and sometimes even all over the
scalp we don't know what's causing it
it's very common
in old people young people it has been
mentioned a thousand years ago and in
most cases it regrows sometimes it
doesn't and then we have to cope with it
which is sometimes not easy and coping
with it is not easy at all and patients
are trying lots of things lots of
different things we got a viewer
question from Munich here in Germany
Munich Ivana wants to know if taking fin
you Greek supplements could reduce hair
falling out in stress like in other
things there are small studies also
about this but it's not really proven
treatment and I would also advise her to
see a hair specialist to really see
what's going on so go and see the doctor
but if I go to say a pharmacy or go into
a supermarket and I find all those
different kinds of shampoos of hair or
which say that they can prevent and even
treat hair loss is any truth to that
most of them them are just cosmetics
they may improve the shine and the
volume of the hair and they are not
proven to really caused regrowth or
thicker hair so it's always better to
focus on medications which are really
tested and proven to work but you would
do this when the hair falls out and can
you prevent hair from falling or say if
you've got great hair and can you
prevent funny out if it's possible to
detect early changes like small
miniaturized shrinking hairs and you
start the treatment early in genetics
inning we can stop the hair loss and
most people stay the same for many years
with tons of letters to this to this
topic so if it's so important for people
out there so why isn't research finding
a cure for hair loss what's the problem
the hair is not easy to study it takes
years to grow it takes months to change
and also there are many changes which
argue to aging of hair and aging in
general is a difficult problem still to
overcome of course and there is a lot of
rich research but it takes many years
but but is there anything in the
pipeline which we can weight forward to
to treat hair loss
than we do today a new approach would be
stem cell therapy it involves taking
good hairs usually from the back of the
scalp then multiplicate in the stem
cells in a laboratory and injecting it
into the scalp but we still don't know
if it really works in a long-term period
dr. Tina thanks so much for being with
us today mr. t thank you
you